For completeness we'll go ahead and
explore duality in the context of
a maximum flow problem as well.
We can cast it as a linear programming
by letting fuv be the flow, and
letting cuv be the capacity
along an edge u,v.
Our goal is to maximize
the flow out of the source
subject to the conservation of flow
constraint and the capacity constraints.
And of course flows must
be non negative as well.
To express the dual, we'll use Yu for
the conservation constraints and
Yuv for the capacity constraints.
Two subscripts mean
a capacity constraint,
one subscript means
a conservation constraint.
The dual problem is to minimize the sum
over all the edges of Yuv times Cuv.
Note that the Yus have no role
in the objection function
because their coefficients are 0.
The constraints for
the dual involve several cases.
We'll consider first those arising from
the objective function coefficients for
edges out of the source being 1.
These flows appear once in
the capacity constraints, and
once for the receiving vertex for
the flow in their conservation equation.
The case for
edges going into the sync is analogous.
The flow is present in
the capacity constraints and
in the conservation of flow
constraint for the sending vertex.
For all other edges the flow
appears in the capacity constraint.
And in the conservation equations for
both the sending and
the receiving vertex.
And of course these dual
variables have to be non-negative.
The interpretation of these dual
variables can be a little tricky, so
I'm going to rearrange them to isolate
the two indexed variables, the ones
corresponding to edges and the ones
that appear in the objective function.
On the left hand side.
This makes it a little easier
to see what's going on.
Actually, I think this
would make a good exercise.